les cervidés mon discours votre mission
plusieurs vous explique vous expliquez
actuellement que ce sont les chefs
d'entreprise qui souhaitent la
nationalisation des entreprises
et comme d'habitude vous avez
parfaitement raison et parce qu'elle
mentor
il est vrai que les chefs d'entreprises
qui sont en faillite n'ont pas
d'objection à ce que l'état en prenne la
responsabilité ça tout le monde le sait
mais en ce qui concerne ce qui vient de
se passer en france c'était pas le camp
les entreprises qui ont été
nationalisées n'étaient pas en fait y
était précisément ce que dit les
socialistes c'est que jusqu'à présent
les états ont recueilli les entreprises
en difficulté mais nous nous sommes plus
intelligents
nous prenons les entreprises qui sont en
prospérité et non entreprises une fois
qu'elles seront nationalisées
deviendront le fer de lance de
l'économie française et nous allons tous
transformés y compris lutter contre le
chômage contre la propriété publique des
entreprises
alors là je crois que si on me contre
eux si vous comprenez exactement vous
êtes plutôt de mon côté c'est à dire que
la nationalisation des entreprises ne
sert à rien pour lutter contre le
chômage par exemple une entreprise
nationalisée peut-être bien gérer une
entreprise privée est mal gérée mais la
représentation
archéo socialiste en france que les
nationalisations des entreprises ce une
transformation fondamentale vous ne le
pensez pas